[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar roll of batch centrifugation
during cell therapy manufacturing
i am marie stone of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
in addition to asking questions we
encourage you to participate in poll
questions at the end of the speaker
presentation
when prompted please click on your
answer when the poll questions are
displayed
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
dr atlee talk application scientist for
thermo fisher scientific dr talk you may
now begin your presentation
thank you very much mary for this nice
introduction and good morning good
afternoon and good evening everyone i'm
very happy to have this chance today to
to give you this talk where i'll be
talking about the rule of bad
centrifugation in this therapy workflow
and while doing so i'm also going to try
to attract your attention to some points
that are either very easily overlooked
or simply unknown to many researchers
let me start with sharing the outline of
my talk for today
some of these points overlapped with
each other to some extent
however for the sake of this talk i
collected the information under the most
relevant titles so that i believe it's
going to help putting things into
context
first of all i'm going to start with
sharing some statistics on the
regenerative marketplace so that we all
get a better understanding of the recent
state of the market
as you all know a market that's
continuously evolving
secondly i will share with you the main
needs of self-happy market especially in
relevance to batch centrifugation
and thirdly i will describe how
centrifugation fits in a typical cell
therapy workflow and then i'm going to
give you i'm going to continue with
giving some tips and considerations that
you can benefit from in order to improve
your self palates in an efficient way
i will also share with you some high
level information
to refresh your knowledge such as
positioning of centrifuges inside
therapy suits
tips for minimizing pellet disruption
and measures to prevent contamination
and so on i'm hoping that this part will
remind you
the points that should be avoided or
should be taken into consideration
at the end of my talk i'm going to also
mention a few equipment features that
can come in handy particularly in cell
type manufacturing that you should look
for in a centrifuge i will finish my
talk
with introducing you our cell therapy
systems cts centrifuge packages that can
help you comply with the regulations and
requirements that cell type developers
need to address
okay so let's get started with
the regenerative medicine marketplace
here is some data summarizing cell
therapy market scene
either you have already made the
transition from the bench to
manufacturing or you are planning on the
next steps to bring your research into
the translational commercial stage these
numbers are quite important to know
in total uh worldwide we are looking at
a picture of a little over 1000
regenerative medicine developers
and 800 ongoing
clinical trials
a significant number of these clinical
trials are in the phase one currently
and even a higher number of trials are
ongoing in phase two
the number of studies that have reached
to the phase three is around 80.
and lastly there are currently
around 22 therapies that have been
approved by fda
and as you all know the overall market
growth is quite rapid and estimated to
pick up an even higher pace in the
coming years
i can imagine you are dialing in from
all over the world so let me show you
also how these regenerative medicine
developers are dispersed around the
globe
most of them are found in north america
and in europe
in the asia's pacific region in the apac
region also the number of actively
developers are quite high more than 200
in total
um
now that we had a brief look into the
regenerative medicine market
it's also important to have a look at
the overall needs of this market so how
bad centrifugation can address to those
needs
i think it's really critical to identify
what one wants to get out of cell
culture centrifugation
first thing is efficiency
centrifugation should guarantee optimal
separation for your product of interest
um
a simplified process
of course is always beneficial which can
be performed easily without cumbersome
preparation and operation
and of course minimize risk of
contamination as the samples are very
valuable and contamination code could
require require really lengthy
procedures to get rid of and also risk
the success of the treatment plan
efficient centrifugation is in return
key for maintaining the cell viability
by applying necessary g-forces and
avoiding the shear stress
cells can proliferate at optimum rates
which will then supply the downstream
application in an uninterrupted way
down the scheme we have output yields
and experimental can secure yield by
benefiting from the flexibility the
centrifuge can provide
scaling up or scaling out
by scaling up
for allergenic studies for instance or
scaling out when you are focusing on
autologous studies you can achieve your
desired deals
and but the rule of thumb here is
that it's necessary to take actions to
minimize cell loss by optimizing your
protocol
and choosing the right instruments to
run your
protocol
we can further separate needs of the
cell therapy market
into two main categories that bad
centrifuges should address
first of all performance related needs
no doubt they are vital for cell engine
therapy manufacturing secondly
compliance related
needs
i will start with the performance
related needs first of all we have
reproducibility which is key
the same performance should be expected
from the equipment run after run
regardless of changes in cell density
volume or factors like environmental
conditions
easy configurability is another point of
utmost significance to ensure that
your protocols are edited and saved
without any trouble and you can expect
the same result from your experiments
every time
as i had just mentioned in the previous
slide
the yield has to be kept at the maximum
so that the downstream steps are not
negatively affected
and
versatility the equipment should allow
users to scale up or scale out without
any problems
and the ability of repurposing to other
steps in the workflow in other words
capability
to be used in other applications such as
molecular biology applications or other
bioprocessing applications not only
limited to cell engine therapy
applications
timely service and support is of course
other crucial points as you would all
agreed with
um
and lastly
this
decreased or prevented down times
which will protect scheduling and
planning efforts i will come back to
this point again later in my talk i will
share with you
a particular centrifuge feature that we
offer that we think can help with the
prevention of downtime
while fulfilling these needs cell
therapy manufacturers
should also always keep in mind that the
process or product in this case must
also comply with standards and
regulations
therefore having an equipment that have
certified cgmp and clean room
compatibility is really key
this will help users
jump start their validation processes
which can otherwise very lengthy and
very resource consuming
um the documentation must be also
traceable and readily available
when notified buddies inquire about them
also anything that the product goes
through all the information on the
processing conditions alarms or alerts
must be saved and accessed easily
so
here is our uh value proposition as time
of fisher scientific centrifuge business
unit
we are offering versatile solutions for
cell engine therapy manufacturing
applications to achieve safe
reproducible results with consistent
quality and performance while minimizing
efforts for regulatory compliance from
the start
now let's have a look at how
centrifugation
plays a role in cell and gene therapy
manufacturing
what we see here is a typical cell
therapy workflow it has two main
segments the first part the upper part
is the upstream segment and it entails
all the steps from cell source
cell isolation and cell culture
expansion including genetic modification
and scaling up or out
and when we look at the cell isolation
step when
and size weight selection is the is the
preferred method of course
centrifugation becomes the method of
choice for a variety of cell types
and density gradients for instance to
get mononuclear cells from peripheral or
cold blood or bone marrow is one of the
most common applications of centrifuges
in this workflow
during the psychology expansion step
cells are palliated and dissolved in
fresh media distributed into fresh
containers metabolic rates by-products
cell debris all are washed away
when felt behind culturing schedule
so contact inhibition or too high
confidence actually can cause cell
stress and negatively affect your
application when it happens it takes a
certain period of time for the cells to
reach desired growth rates
and to show wild-type characteristics or
behavior
in order to ensure meaningful results
from the experiments
or to have reproducible results timely
subculturing practice is actually key
when we look at the downstream segments
in the
below part of the scheme
we see that it involves harvesting of
cells their preservation storage and
release of the end product
harvesting is the last step of the
downstream process where centrifugation
has a really pronounced use in this step
the main purpose is to concentrate cells
by pelleting but at the same time of
course
excess growth media serum is all gotten
rid of as a rule of thumb one needs to
pay attention to resuspend the sap
palette as quick as possible so that
unnecessary stress is prevented
now i would like to
put what i have shared with you in this
scheme into a more solid context by
taking a conventional
car t cell therapy workflow as an
example
um
so this workflow
starts with t cells being isolated from
patient's blood
in order to do so uh leukopherosis which
is basically a centrifugation method is
commonly applied to isolate t cells
however this can also be
achieved in
a conventional batch centrifuge as well
isolated t cells are then activated
actuated t cells are then genetically
modified so that they express specific
cars chimeric antigen receptors
and this is done via either lentiviral
systems or crispr cast 9 system and
these genetically modified cells are
expanded x vivo
and the where centrifuges are again
of use repeatedly
lastly the cells are harvested
and prepared for retransformation
is in the case of autologous treatments
or
transformation as it is in the case of
allogeneic
cell therapies
and again eventually harvesting is the
last step of the salt therapy workflow
where centrifugation has a pronounced
use
let's continue with another case study
this time
i'd like to
briefly show you this workflow that
belongs to aav production
in this case
particles of interest are viral
particles so they are collected with
culture medium from flasks
clarification of wire particles are
achieved in base centrifuges at around
10 000 g at 4 degrees celsius
um supernatant which includes the wire
particles is collected and the pallet
the cell debris is discarded
uh just before purification
uh tubes that have the gradient media
must be prepared so the layering of
gradient media using syringes or needles
in ultra centrifuge tubes is completed
samples are placed on this prepared
layered medium as you all know
separation then is done using
ultra speed centrifuges with sieving out
rotor configurations for best separation
effect
um
so finally viral particles are collected
in biosafety cabinets using needle to
puncture the seal tube or eliquids and
then liquid them into tubes for quality
control using real-time pcr
um so far
i've shown you how centrifuge fits in
the general scheme
however it's also quite important to
know about
some of the other main instruments of
cell type workflow
i will now show you briefly how
centrifuges interact with other
laboratory devices
and in this slide what we see is that
the cryopreserve samples are first towed
and cell culture is started
top culturing and the treatment of
cultures are usually performed in
biosafety cabinets and expansion is
achieved in carbon dioxide incubators
and carbon dioxide resistance shakers
in order to prevent any unwanted results
for your purposes
one must really make sure that every
element of this workflow functions in
harmony
and
this certainly requires
a particular level of innovative
interface where all these single
elements
match with each other in technological
levels in order to have certain
performance in a standardized manner
and to make sure everything goes okay
having said that
i think it's only natural to ask whether
there are any other separation methods
or not well the answer is yes of course
there are for sure other methods and
devices on the market
let's now have a look at why we
recommend bad centrifugation
so as the time official scientific
centrifuge business unit we recommend
bad centrifugation due to the fact that
bait centrifugation is actually
independent of
many of the factors or all of the
factors listed here first of all base
centrifugation is not affected by cell
type specificity
doesn't matter if you are working with
mesenchymal stem cells or car t cells
bath centrifugation can be successfully
applied
you can harvest
high cell densities conveniently as
clogging is not a problem like in some
other techniques
also with refrigeration capabilities you
don't have to worry about maintaining
the right temperature you can expect to
have reproducible results
and lastly
exceeding shearing forces
or
void volume are other two factors that
pet centrifugation is not affected by
also made centrifuges they come with
some added benefits
low cost of maintenance and operation
low initial capital investment
uncomplicated process development and
lastly
bad centrifuges can be used in or
repurposed in other processes and
workflows as well
uh as they are really versatile
devices having said that i think it's
also a good time
now
uh
to continue with tips and considerations
regarding bad centrifugation
uh and so that you get what you aim for
honestly speaking i didn't know
many of these points that i'm going to
share right now
during my previous research positions
and i hope that you will also find these
helpful let's start with the centrifuge
positioning in salsa if you are in cell
culture suits
um one thing we would all agree i guess
is that as much as uh it gets more
competitive to receive research grants
to receive funds and but it also the
same applies to laboratory space
uh also the running costs of clean room
environments can be quite high nowadays
for one thing really
lab space is valuable and therefore you
must make sure that you have a strategy
when you are positioning your lab
instruments
especially as a centrifuge as um as it
produces tens of thousands of g-force um
it will inevitably vibrate and therefore
it can interfere with other laboratory
instruments no need to say one such
instrument is microscopes and this was
pretty much what i knew before
um
uh during my previous research research
positions not to put a centrifuge next
to a microscope but
the question is what we can do about it
so centrifuges they can actually be
placed on separate bench modules
or floor standing models it's this
rollers can be also preferred and they
can be repositioned when needed in
addition to these possible
interference to fine instruments like
microscopes there's also a lot more to
it when positioning a microscope
sorry a centrifuge
let me share with you these two
scenarios
in one setup on the left hand side
biosafety cabinet and incubator are
located
close to each other but the centrifuge
is on the other end of the room
in the second setup on the right hand
side
a all three elements are very close to
place to each other
the green color in these two scenarios
actually denotes the experimental
experimenter in the scheme and i would
like to direct this question to you
please take a second to answer
yourselves answer to yourselves
basically which positioning is the
better option in your opinion
the answer is actually the second option
on the right hand side
so the first scenario would require a
lot more personal movement in the lab
because the elements the devices are far
away from each other and this can
actually
cause
lifting up
aerosols and dust particles from the
floor and cause them to
circulate in the air that can be a
potential risk factor a contamination
factor for your samples for that reason
personal movements should be minimized
when possible
and this is not going to ensure this is
not only going to ensure really uh
increased efficiency but it's also going
to help mitigate potential contamination
risks
one possible alternative and a very
flexible solution to prevent unnecessary
movements would be again using
centrifuges with lockable casters
these floor standing units so that
you can position the centrifuge wherever
they are needed basically and in crowded
conditions
of um many south culture suites this
floor standing centrifuges and rollers
uh can really provide the very much
needed
adaptability
and perhaps some of you thought scenario
one was better scenario on the left-hand
side was really the option to choose
because you might have thought that
centrifuges produce large amounts of
aerosol during runs
therefore it's best to keep them away
from biosafety cabinets to prevent
contamination which is of course a
correct approach and actually we also
wanted to test this idea and my
colleagues checked this in-house where
there are centrifuges which breach the
air barrier of our biosafety cabinets
and the results turned out to be more
than satisfactory the air barrier was
not really breached at all by our
running centrifuges
so what does it how does it helps by
place by safely placing the centrifuge
near you by a safety cabinet the
researcher can access the sensory future
without even getting up from the labs
tool at the same time it gives the
ability to monitor the runtime easily um
what i'm really trying to emphasize here
is that choosing the right equipment
as in any other application
in any other setting can really
stop a lot of potential issues
from evolving into troubling problems in
the future so
from the start actually you can go for
some improvements in your workflow by
choosing the right equipment
i would like to now change to
um
cell culture centrifugation and want to
also
give you some tips and considerations
for cell culture centrifugation in the
rule of time one should always keep in
mind all the time throughout the therapy
workflow that mammalian cells are very
very delicate and in some cases such a
fact is easily overlooked by the
researcher and the yield suffers
for no reason not necessarily it's also
it's only noticed
as a problem once the yield decreases to
uh noticeable levels
due to
their delicate nature mammalian cells
are centrifuged at
low g forces ranging from 100 times g to
500 times g
while higher g forces
will cause cell damage applying very low
g forces can in turn reduce viability as
the cells will be spending way too much
time outside the incubator this will
then cause diminished growth trades and
it's going to take time until the south
kind of regain their
characteristics again speed up their
proliferation
and these all can have a drastic effects
on the production pipeline actually
and therefore having a complete control
of g4 settings are key
and we recommend choosing a centrifuge
unit that's designed to fine tune your
protocol with increments as small as
five times g
um
this is certainly required to have
the best centrifugation
conditions for yourself and guarantee a
reproducibility for successful
output successful outcomes
um i also like to now share with you
what other biological particles requires
as for rcf values
if we or when we
prefer such values when applying
different protocols
and but i think it's helpful to observe
all of them at once this will i hope
put the
requirements for cell culture
centrifugation into a better context by
comparing it to other biological
particles so at the right hand side at
the higher end of this g-force axis
x-axis we do have small proteins and
plasmids
and small viruses and nanoparticles that
they usually
require application of hundreds of
thousands of g
large viruses
lipoproteins and organelles together
with large proteins and micromolecules
are found on the left-hand side of the
rcf range
at the
lower end of this chart at the
very left hand side there are whole
cells that require low g values as i
mentioned uh to ensure efficient um
ensure efficient separation while
maintaining cell viability
so so far we have covered some important
considerations on where to play
centrifuges and some tips
on
psychology centrifugation let's continue
with
some tips on how to improve actually
your
uh
with
base centrifugation
um
the rotor type you you choose is of
course matters for one thing
use of sieving bucket rotors rather than
fixed angle rotors will provide
palleting at the bottom of the tube in a
homogeneous manner really however with
fixed angle rotors and cells will start
pelleting on the wall of the tube and
during centrifugation process they will
kind of slide down the tube as you can
imagine this can easily damage the
mammalian cells and decrease the yield
eventually in a very drastic manner
one thing
that i had no idea about during my
previous research years was the fact
that the choice of the duplication
in
in an adapter actually would make a
difference
so different tube slots
they make a different angle to the
rotation axis
so the center tubes
in this
in the blue
part you see them
marked with green dots
they are almost perfect in line with the
rotation axis
the neighboring tubes however they
receive the
centrifugal force with a small angle and
therefore the pelleting in those
neighboring
tubes won't be as even therefore you can
expect
to get the most even pallets
from the central tubes here also denoted
again with the green dots in the in the
bottom part
um as i already mentioned earlier
gradients are sometimes used when
isolating cells for instance fico
gradient is commonly used
to isolate mononuclear cells from
bone marrow or from peripheral bloods
in order to increase the throughput one
can plan to use larger tubes naturally
however this might not help with yield
as and the reason is as follows so the
interfaces are so delicate that they can
easily be disrupted as you know and cell
laws can occur in larger tubes
this can happen even more readily due to
the fact that the interface area between
these layers is also larger
therefore our suggestion is using
actually thinner tubes for instance
using 15 ml conical tubes instead of 50
ml conical tubes when you are doing
dense degrading centrifugation with your
cell culture samples
as easy as these gradient layers can
disrupt and can mix up it also holds
true for pallets until the rotor is
completely stopped basically the
centrifugation
protocol is not over yet so the last
step of centrifugation which is the
breaking step can actually cause a lot
of problems by disrupting your nicely
formed sub pellets as a rule of thumb
faster breaking usually correlates more
with more higher pallet disruption
during breaking what really happens in
the tubes is that
there is this angular momentum
and it causes the so-called coriolis
forces so this forces this movement is
greatest
under fast breaking so it's this
movement in the liquid that will release
cells from the surface of the pallet
and
cause the disruption of the pallet
here you see a deceleration profile
this belongs to a specific rotor
centrifuge
combination
as
rotor and centrifuge capabilities vary a
lot among different manufacturers there
is no
standardization when it comes to
acceleration or deceleration profiles
asking for a deceleration profile from
the centrifuge manufacturer
will help you find a suitable setting
parameter for your application actually
therefore you need to select a breaking
profile
that is slow enough to have no effect on
your pelleting efficiency but quick
enough
to reduce
the time that the cells spend out of the
incubator so that they can maintain
their viability
in conventional centrifuges
the load on the rotor also has a large
effect on the braking efficiency
as an example when you see here
what you see here
shown in red line
it belongs the loaded rotor and an empty
rotor shown with a blue line
you can see on the x-axis is the time
required until the rotor comes to a stop
and it can really differ
drastically so
in this case it's about one and a half
times more
for the loaded rotor to stop
um
actually what is a new technology to
protect your protocol from such
variability is
this microprocessor controlled braking
technology in such a setup your
centrifuge will automatically adjust the
braking power constantly to achieve
reproducible brakes run after run
without being affected by the load in
the rotor
and at different speeds
deceleration is also affected
differently as you may guess at higher
rcf values
in swing out raw for configurations the
bucket orientation is going to be
horizontal so effect of breaking is
going to be minor but at lower speeds
such as 200 g or 100 g breaking is going
to have a more pronounced effect on
deceleration because
during these slower speeds
buckets are start to
reorient
they will go back to these vertical
positions
of
course um
already related some of the earlier
topics reproducibility as i said is an
impact important factor that must be
assured and one main feature of a
centrifuge that can help you get
reproducible results is
is refrigeration
and
because one should keep in mind that
ventilated centrifuges can heat up to
very high temperatures that can risk
your experimental success
especially when using ventilated units
how many centrifuges are found in the
same room how often and how long they
are used are actually very important
factors that can cause um
high temperatures within within
ventilated centrifuges with the
refrigerator centrifuge however
and this risk is minimized and
controlled even when you are
centrifuging your samples at room
temperature
uh you can only make sure your samples
are kept at room temperature if you are
using a refrigerated centrifuge
okay so contamination this is
is in perhaps this is the most uh
treated word
in most biology applications and
especially this is true for cell culture
rooms
however
we actually have the tools to prevent or
minimize it
i already touched upon
this while sharing some tips on
positioning a centrifuge in psychology
room
with regards to risks of irresolves that
are produced during centrifugation
but
what we need to know is that
refrigerated or ventilated units they
both circulate a certain amount of air
when they are cooling down this is
even more pronounced
for ventilated units as they use air as
a medium to cool down their operating
temperature
this air movement can really lift up any
contaminant around or underneath the
centrifuge and disperse it in the room
therefore
good cleaning practices are key to
prevent such unwanted scenarios
um
speaking about cleaning in theory it's
basically the
is a common step universally shared by
any biology experiment but in practice
there's always a lot of room for
improvement when it comes to cleaning
in the laboratories that i've been so
far i've noticed that setting up
schedules and plans we're almost always
done perfectly but as the time passes
like holidays interfere experiments pile
up and you basically need to produce
your data so the first thing that legs
behind would be cleaning procedures
especially in a cell culture suit this
would be unacceptable so our
recommendation is also choosing a
centrifuge that offers it to remove
rotors without the need of any kind of
specialized tools this will
help ensure in quick access to the
centrifuge ball and therefore cleaning
will be performed easier and
cleaning practices will be will be stuck
too and will be followed better
another tip that's worth sharing here is
i think to make sure that there is no
spillage on the outside of the tube
walls and no liquid really gets captured
in the bottle threads that might then
leak into the buckets
during centrifugation and act as a
potential contaminant contamination risk
for your samples
after
so we have been
uh going through we have gone through
some general tips and considerations
now i'd like to go quickly over some key
centrifuge features
that are particularly useful in cell
therapy manufacturing let's start with
access control function
um
so you can find this function in our
most of our
centerfish portfolio
it's called secure mode it really comes
in very handy
so how it works is as follows in order
to create
edit delete programs
or
basically access
any kind of display control or alarm
settings
or in order to
connect the unit to a wired network the
user needs to enter a passcode
and this access control feature it
increases the safety of the cell therapy
product
because only the accredited personnel
can make can make such changes so you
can make sure of the safety of your
product
while it is in the centrifuge
thermo fisher scientific centrifuges
also
come
with a function called ace
a stands for accumulated centrifugal
effect
so this function
ensures the reproducibility of your
manufacturing steps really
this mode ensures that no matter how
much sample
is loaded into the rotor that be it one
liter or 10 milliliter the samples are
applied the same g-force
in
the differences between
acceleration rates due to different
sample weights unit condition unit h
altitude they're all taken into account
automatically and the rounds are
prolonged if necessary so that the
piloting efficiency does not vary due to
sample load and this is extremely
important in case of cell engine turkey
manufacturing applications particularly
in autologous applications because
sampled sample variation is quite high
there are also other tools that you can
make use of in your daily centrifugation
routine one such useful tool is the
click seal by containment lids
these lids provide an airtight ceiling
over your sample so that not only the
samples are protected but also
laboratory or clean room environment is
also protected against possible
contaminations possible
leaking issues
um what we
suggest is that choosing where
containment lets
that
um that allow the users to open and
close them with only one hand
and so this feature will ensure that
actually these tools are used this by
containment lists are used and your
samples
are
are the safest
um
continuing with with another uh
important feature
uh it's called health status and it can
be found in our general purpose benchtop
centrifuge portfolio
is so what you see here is graphical
user interface
the user basically can view the stats of
the unit or the router loaded in the
unit
by just pressing a button here it's
shaped as a green heart
it really helps the user to take
preventative measures in order to
minimize or inhibit down times
altogether so this is a great feature
that ensures
high performance
why is it important in cell therapy
applications because especially again
for autologous style therapy
manufacturing
donor to donor variability
it's extra complexity to to design in
process design or scheduling attempts
so what's really needed is an always
ready units that you can process your
sample with as soon as your sample is
available
um
i like to also
highlight here taking the opportunity is
that refrigerated floor units
uh i told you about how
handy they can be in really a small
clean room environment small
cell culture suites
because
they have the same footprint as
ventilated bench units
so
this is one
advantage that they bring onto the table
and secondly thanks to their locking
casters they can also be easily moved
for relocation or cleaning purposes so
again this will help to stick your
cleaning regimen
okay i like to
i'm coming to
the uh final part of my talk i'd like to
really take this opportunity and also
briefly introduce you the our general
purpose
style therapy systems cts centrifuge
package
in this package there are
uh our
gmp focus four liters general purpose
centrifuges as well as our
high capacity four liter receiving
outdoors or tx1000 you see it in the
first box on the left-hand side
and also multiple adapters that are
mostly used in cell therapy
manufacturing applications
additionally
qualification services such as
installation operation and performance
qualifications iq or qpq they're also
included in this package what i like to
spend some more time is
actually the documentation finder
that this package includes
um so in this so-called cts series
binder
there are mainly some traceability
certificates found
first of all
vaporized hydrogen peroxide
compatibility certification as you know
vhp is widely used uh the widely used
contamination methods in clean rooms and
our gp centrifuges have been tested for
hydrogen peroxide compact compatibility
and by exposing them to several
decontamination cycles and they
performed
[Music]
optimally
secondly
practic a particle emission certificate
is also included in this binder the
certificate shows that the units
do not really jeopardize clean room
integrity up to iso 7 grain
grade clean rooms lastly a certification
of containment
for by containment that are included
going further a certificate of
conformance is included in the binder
this is a serial number specific proof
that the unit actually performs
according to design
build and functional specifications
additionally a key material of
construction document is also included
so that users wouldn't need to invest
any resources in collection of this
information
after the sales it helps incredibly with
with the uh internal validation efforts
lastly iso 9001 and 13
485 certificates they're also included
in binder to prove adherence to global
cgmp guidelines
i would like to end my talk by also
sharing with you
how this
cts series package can help you so what
is it good for
now that we know what is inside it so
overall it's a package
that
that is designed for cell therapy
manufacturing
it has carefully collated documentation
that will help jumpstart regulatory
compliance from start a traceability
documentation
is going to be always at hand from the
start
a proven clean room compatibility will
really guarantee a straightforward
internal validation
and
all the resources basically require to
collect such documentation after
uh sales is diminished so you can really
research the focus on your research or
your manufacturing workflow instead of
collecting documentation
lastly
i want to end my talk with a photo
from the june lab at the university of
pennsylvania
which has which accomplished the first
approved cell therapy product where you
can see the nodes from the left-hand
side with a red arrow a thermoscientific
centrifuge in use and i would like to
add that the swinging rotor
centrifugation is still the workhorse of
salt ip manufacturing globally
if you are
if you want to have more information you
can always email me you see my email
address at the left bottom corner of
every slide basically
you can also visit thermofisher.com to
reach
several application notes white papers
guidelines
and product portfolio
i'd like to
thank you very much for your attention
and now i'm looking forward to your
questions thank you
thank you dr talk for your informative
presentation
before we start the live q a portion of
the webinar we have a few poll questions
and encourage you to participate
our first poll question is
what is the average culture volume per
therapy you're working with
less than one liter one to four liters
over four liters
simply click on your selection for this
particular poll question
what is the average culture volume per
therapy you're working with
our second poll question which steps of
a cell therapy manufacturing workflow do
you use a centrifuge
isolation expansion
or harvesting
please click on your selection for this
poll question
which steps of a cell therapy
manufacturing workflow do you use a
centrifuge
in our last poll question
what cell type do you work with
t cells stem cells
or others please specify
and if your selection is others we ask
that you
type your cell type that you work with
into the chat
for this webinar
and then those answers will be collected
so what cell type do you work with t
cells stem cells or others
and please specify your answer for
others in the chat
all right and we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
how can the user retrieve the run log
from your cts series centrifuges
this is actually a very good question
because as i said in my
talk data logging is definitely a
crucial part of cell therapy
manufacturing
and
in our general purpose pro models it's
actually performed automatically
so data logging is completed
automatically and all the data about the
centrifuge and the runs are stored on
the device
these pro models they are equipped with
both
usb and
rs232 ports for data extraction
but
in general usb connectivity makes it
really extremely easy to
import data by simply plugging in a usb
stick
the slot can be found on the on the
front panel of the device and then
the user can export the data using the
directives that are shown on the
graphical user interface
if
the rs232 port is used the user can also
monitor
the target and actual
belonging to the run conditions from
their computer so they can
check
the acceleration profile deceleration
profile the target speed and the current
speed as well as the rcf value remaining
runtime temperature and so on
great thank you this is yeah
question yes thank you
next question
you mentioned about the alarm alert
function which parameters does it
monitor
it's a good question because it is again
directly related to
sample safety
a alarm function
has
or alarm function
basically
gives information about the running
conditions
uh today to the user so if the
temperature
drops too low or if it rises too high
then there's an alarm or if there is any
rotor imbalance during the acceleration
the unit notices this and notifies the
user and it's also not an only audible
alarm but
the user can also see the error codes on
the graphical user interface
and
they can also see the task
text descriptions on the screen and
directions basically on the ongoing
issue
if it is related to kind of a
maintenance
action if a maintenance action is due
or there is kind of a minor disturbance
on the safe operation of the centrifuge
again the unit uh basically um
gives an alert uh the user must correct
the root cause as soon as possible so
that the uh sample integrity is is
maintained
great thank you
next question
can we purchase iq
oqpq separately
um
so
there are actually two options for the
cts series that i mentioned in one
option
is centrifuge rotor and adapters
accessories as well as this
factory acceptor spider are included
so this is one basically packaged and in
the second option there's also
additionally iq oqp services are
included um
so these two options they do actually
come with different product numbers uh
long story short yes these services can
be vote separately so yeah the local
sales representatives
would inform you the best on this
thank you
and it looks like we have time for one
more question
how do you make use of the ace function
how can you determine the ace value
this is again a good question because i
mentioned how useful this ace function
was accumulated centrifugal effect
function because it would really um
a
so no matter the rotor load environment
conditions altitude you still can expect
to get the same result so it's really a
guarantee for reproducibility
um but
it also needs to be understood well so
it's basically not uncalculated value it
is a value that is determined and for
its determination the user basically
needs a stopwatch
what you need is a already successfully
running protocol so that you know the
optimal time for a successful separation
and you know at what speed value your
centrifugation needs to run
and
instead of the time
in order to determine ace value one
basically chooses a high ace value
and
the speed
and the
acceleration and deceleration
settings are entered the centrifuges
started and the stopwatch is basically
as the stopwatch reaches the optimal run
time
the value that is
shown on the screen is written down so
with that ace value you can basically
in a very trouble-free manner you can
transfer your running protocol to any
other um
equivalent centrifuge you have uh in
your cell therapy switch
great you also have an app excuse me we
also have an application note on this so
feel free to reach out or
visit our website
thank you dr talk do you have any final
comments for our audience
no i hope um they will be leaving this
talk today uh with with some new
information
it's an it's an evolving field so
uh there are so there's
some standards are not still established
so i would be very interested in hearing
more about their workflows their
applications
so please feel free to reach out to me
and also if you have any questions about
the units if you're interested in
acquiring them yeah this local sales
representatives would be your best
contact in this
thank you
great well thank you again dr talk for
your time today and your important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor thermo fisher
scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye
you